i remember in this view of life you were
talking about
how the europeans used to go and
study other cultures and rate them
essentially on a scale of civilized to
savage
and that was the wrong way of obviously
the wrong way of going about it
a better way was to be would be
something akin to looking at the inuit
and seeing how they're accustomed to the
cold and they have their own practices
to deal with it
and then we can say oh they're not
savage they're adapted to that
environment
okay so then my question was they're
adapted because they survive well in
that environment
then the europeans came along and
invented cities and
technology and now they can survive in
alaska and
the coldest parts of the world maybe
better but that's a question i want to
ask you is what does it mean to be
adapted
and if and if these white europeans
let's just call them white europeans
came and settled
and now made brick houses with fire and
electricity that
goes right through are they not more
adapted than
the inuit then because they're able to
survive better in these colder
environments
oh yeah there's a whole bunch of things
you raised there so let's try to unpack
them
one by one i'm lucky
to be trained as an evolutionary
biologist a lot of people that are
playing this game
were trained in some of the human
related disciplines and they picked up
their
evolutionary theory playing what game uh
well the whole thinking of all aspects
of humanity from an evolutionary
perspective basically this view of life
um extending evolutionary thinking to
explain all aspects of
of humanity that's the game that i'm
sorry you mean to say that you have the
advantage
in that you were in constant
evolutionary thinking first then started
to apply it out where yeah
other people yeah and actually yeah and
i'm a bit unusual
that way the reason i mention it is that
sophisticated evolutionary thinking
includes
basically showcases adaptation
but there's a lot of other stuff as well
and so when we look at things that are
out there
sometimes they're adaptive sometimes
they're not even when they're adaptive
then what counts as adaptive in the
evolutionary sense of the word doesn't
necessarily correspond to in the
normative
sense of the word so back to the way we
should be looking at cultures
and during the victorian victorian era
it was uh
very difficult for darwin along with his
colleagues to not to think of european
culture as superior in some sense
to all other cultures yet a more true
evolutionary approach as you just said
would be that most cultures
are at least to some degree well adapted
to their
circumstances and so uh that's a more
respectful
way to approach cultures and one which
is truer to evolutionary
uh theorists so in that sense uh the
inuits are better adapted to an arctic
climate than
than uh europeans at least at first now
you're saying
that um
such modern conveniences is housing and
and um heating and
so on is well adapted and of course
those have been
adopted by inuits they don't live in
igloos
but if they did let's imagine that there
are some that still do well i mean
that's not imaginary there's all kinds
of uh
uh indigenous people that uh
actually want to want to stick to their
indigenous
uh ways and
to to a greater or lesser degree and
and one point to make i think is that
that should be their choice
so uh and you see
very interesting regions such as ecuador
which have still a
large indigenous and diverse
you know many tribes in ecuador that are
now being represented in
in in the government
and so it's like our choice what do we
want to do do we want to
modernize our or not often they might i
mean such things as
as medicine i mean who wants to do
without modern medicine not many
people so so
it's a it's a very complex situation but
one which needs to be handled
in a uh egalitarian
fashion that acquires respect to all of
the different
uh uh stakeholders there's a sense in
which and this is once again
the egalitarian impulse no matter who i
am what culture i represent
uh there's some sense in which i need to
be a moral equal
and that my existence counts
i have some kind of say in the
decision-making process based on
my values and so
that's the that's the concept of moral
equality which i think is pretty much
culturally universal not restricted to
weird
societies is that however the us gets
defined
then then there's some uh
feeling of of equality and that that has
a
a
an insistent dimension basically not
only am i a moral equal but i will
resist you
if you infringe upon infringe upon that
so if we're going to do something
together it has to be in some sense
why with my uh acquiescence
i have to i have to be able to say yes
to that